so obviously the level design is
fantastic and it's really great about
funneling you back in making those
shortcuts maybe you like I don't know
people are comparing to Dark Souls but
why does Kratos have to climb onto the
chain every time you kick it down dude I
don't know here's what I want to know
how come with all of that awesome gear
there's no helmet for Kratos it just
looks odd to have his bald head poking
out the whole time definitely weird
right that's why you gave it a 9
so all kidding aside Corey it's awesome
happy here to chat about god of war
everyone in the office loves it a whole
lot
Kratos Senate race are obviously super
interesting but I want to know more
about is how you guys leveraged Norse
mythology there's a lot of material
there how did you know what to use what
not to use that that was a a long long
process is the instinct in the beginning
that you just want to overload
everything you just want to put
everything in and interestingly the
first script we drafted I had to pretty
much pull the plug on it was one of the
writers that we had working for a
shameless gang put a lot of hard and
soul into that one and I realized when
we were at like a really crude rough
draft form that we were writing the
second game that we were suddenly so
deep into the mythology that it was
taking center stage and the father-son
story was actually getting pushed aside
a little bit there was a lot of amazing
ideas and there ADIZ I hope to use in
the future but that one really kind of
centered me realized okay gotta step
back gotta start over got to focus it in
on I think the things that are not the
the sort of main pop-culture
understandings right so Marvel brings us
the understanding of Loki and Thor and
ant
Hopkins and I realize like look people
know that but that's not what's gonna
get him into our world what's gonna get
me tour well there's really centering
around Kratos and radiating out with
stories that feel like you connect with
these people that it feels like you're
hearing somebody recount a story from
the bar the other day but it really
actually is a piece of mythology it
feels less than like a lecture like a
like a bit of an education more like oh
that's crazy I wonder if I'm going to
run into that person yeah that was the
connection we really wanted people to
have so it never felt like you were
overwhelmed or you hadn't studied the
night before I feel like he's leading
into discussion of Mamere because
because he he really was sort of giving
me all those bits and pieces like the
tantalizing dark mythology that I really
didn't know a whole lot about and that
wasn't the focus of the game like how
did you balance his character because it
was one of the most fascinating pieces
of the games because everywhere I was
going I was passively learning something
yeah
he ballooned up a lot because initially
when we talked about Mamere
he was going to be the disembodied head
that would be in a bag kratos would have
this little fanny pack and then every
you know the magical fanny pack that
held everything and then said he was
sacrifice came out right it was
interesting because that we had gotten
farther down the road like i swear they
are amazing over there but i was utterly
convinced they had our office bugged
because the number of times I was like
I'd watch one of those dev Diaries
because I watched every single one of
those they came out who's talking to me
right just so frustrated they know about
this they're doing you know cut camera
now what's wrong cuz our game was taking
so long I felt like everything's gonna
be done by the time we get this thing
finished everyone else has already done
all these cool ideas but Mamere was in
the bag and then we would pull him out
occasionally just a few times for
conversation but then I realized like
you know what would be awesome is if he
was hanging on his belt and if you were
to stand still you'd be seeing this
disembodied head kind of blinking and
looking around I was like I think this
is an opportunity we were sort of
missing something but I knew if I just
sprung it on people
I just said hey we're gonna have the
talking head he's gonna hang from there
people get very upset I was gonna be
comical you know it's not gonna work so
I just started mentioning it in reviews
every once in a while I was like yeah
you know I wonder if his head hanging
off the belt because you know what let's
focus on this thing you know just every
once in a while throwing the
conversation till I finally just said by
the way
lemierre's has gonna be hanging off your
belt and he's gonna tell you stories and
we're gonna rely on him playing these
stories out like we had been doing all
this research seeing that there's so
much fantastic mythology but he's the
perfect guy to say oh I know this person
right he gives you his personal sort of
opinion but she's a lot she lied
some people value the privacy best not
to judge brother when I require your
counsel head
I will ask good enough it makes it feel
again less like I'm trying to remember
this because some of these names are
really hard to pronounce like we we
tried to stay true to the names of
characters and places but plaintiffs
kept yielding the result of like you
know I'm so confused by the location
like Conan's guard RVer guard when you
see it written is very intimidating with
the umlauts so we had to balance how
much we could get into it and how much
more could it just be like talking about
a person here you love when you get into
the boat in the mirror he put his head
on the bench next at Reyes I thought
that was great I didn't even notice that
at first but did you know right away
from the get-go when you sat down in
what 2013 to start making this game that
was gonna be Norse mythology no no no I
I me my wife is Swedish so I knew that
there was a desire to kind of
investigate that mythology it was more
about learning about her her culture and
their past but I wanted to kind of get a
little sliver of a lot of mythology so
when I came back I started doing the
Cliff Notes version of all these
different mythology I got to get a
flavor of what they were about and you
know Egyptian was always fascinating to
me
it it sort of had a geography problem of
if he's gonna want to get away from his
past that's not far enough away right
and there's also these great stories
within there that you know the Pharaohs
are kind of like the physical
manifestations of the gods right that
the gods talking about the gods even
walking the earth they never really were
doing that a lot of it was the the sort
of living in other worlds so there was
some interesting stuff but when I first
read some of the Eddas and these were
translations of the Eddas and I was just
kind of delving in not really going deep
I started seeing some of this as a humor
right some of that weird dry and
slightly dark and and twisted sense of
humor that the Scandinavians have and
that was what first started to attract
me to it to say like we're gonna have a
game that probably gonna be very long we
cannot be serious all the time it has to
have moments of levity and the Mileva T
has to feel like it's rooted in the
mythology but also genuine right as
opposed to playing for a gag right and
we were very cognizant of that
throughout to make sure we were not just
trying to tell jokes
if that kills us that's it no voila no
else ever it does not attack mom made
them some more dangerous than that then
do not drop your guard gum as I kept
circling around to the different
mythology I realized like there is an
order in which we're probably going to
go to each one of these and reading
about each one of them allowed me to
understand this is probably a really
good order and the first one out is
North Smith one because choosing the
location or the time period being a pre
migration right which is this massive
expanse of time that we don't have to
commit to when this happened but it's
also the isolation right Kratos and the
tray us against the world they are
isolated not a lot of friends and the
very few people that they interact with
still feels like it's just monsters and
these few people I think that's the
fertile ground for character one scene
later on the game where you find that
missing piece from that ruin the trap
was it what Reyes was reading and
there's like oh there's a piece missing
and then it's the one depicting a hip
tear in the middle of it's like the the
Greek symbol for it's like the Omega
something or whatever we were theorizing
basically like it's that kind of like
you said like Norse was the first
mythology you want to go do but then you
also see the Triskelion the Triskelion
and then you see the Eye of Horus I
might be butchering which these are that
an intent maybe down the road to build a
larger universe outside of just Greek
and Norse there is a connection to that
its first goal was to show how tear
connected to all these other mythologies
here was kind of the first god of war
within the north's realm kind of got
screwed over by the gods right and as
sort of pushed aside and Odin kind of
took over in that respect and
we portrayed him as this interesting
kind of like the the more beloved God
the God who actually connected to other
mythologies other cultures and was
trying to unify and bring them together
but the kind of rabble rousers of the
easiest sort of ruins that and there's
these references in the mythology of
actually having certain characters
actually reference or interact with say
the Roman gods which I thought was
always fascinating that I don't know if
it's simply a later translation or even
when the the Christians started to move
Norse mythology to away from paganism
and more towards Christianity that maybe
they had folded some of these things in
but I was love the idea that on the
planet you know since the beginning of
time all these cultures are having their
origin stories right and geography is
separating all of them so that
concurrently all these mythologies are
going on right there isn't one that says
this is how everything was it was this
is how this culture was brought up and
this culture was brought up in this way
and who knows if they were to criss
cross and have some crazy Norse and
Egyptian and my injustice league of
people speaking of creation stories I
like that
Freya's houses on the back of a turtle
that Native American myths kind of
coming into it maybe that's what I first
thought well that's cool actually I
would love to say oh that's totally
whatever I mean there but when we talked
about the the design of her house I had
said look I want to do something really
cool here I want when you go to
Sanctuary Grove to feel like you're
stepping into you know what dreams may
come kind of painting right that's a
very good point of reference yeah
because if it definitely was that yeah
early surreal yeah totally bursting with
color and really a sense of hope that
wasn't present in the previous
franchises and I think this idea that it
wasn't coming in the beginning but then
the larger world starts to open up and
you experienced the the fantastic right
the movies of my youth that were sort of
formative for me never any stories when
I referenced all the time which has the
sense
that you know it is a storybook come to
life and so much possibility and I said
I would love it if she like lived inside
of a creature or something like that and
I know that's crazy because we were in
heavy scoping at the time so everything
was too expensive and I couldn't I
needed to start trimming everything down
because it was way too big and
everyone's freaking out and the art
director at the time had actually said
all right well we'll take a look at this
almost bring some people in a room and
we'll just talk and see what happens I
can't promise anything
the creatures a little crazy you know
they're freaking out on the schedule
side so he comes back and says all right
so there's something I want to pitch you
and something I don't want to piss you
and I know you're gonna want me to pitch
you the one I don't want to pitch you
but let me pitch you this other stuff
and then we'll go to the thing I don't
want to pitch you and we can you know we
can't afford it so you know don't fall
in love with it and I was like that is
the worst pitch ever because you know
that's all I'm gonna care about it at
that point so he pitch me showed me a
couple of the drawings that they did
when they were in the room talking I was
like oh that's cool this is nice this is
alright and they said alright and then
I'll just tell you the thing that seemed
to be the one resonating the room but we
totally can't do it is that maybe her
house is underneath a turtle and I was
like it's happening like this is the
magic moment let's look remember this
because it's a turtle it's a turtle like
it's happening and he's just like damn
it so then I got into lots of arguments
with the producers and begged and
pleaded and agreed to cut some other
stuff which I didn't later
I always do that I always make the
promise that okay if I do this I promise
I will get rid of something at a later
date let's talk about it next week and
then I delay the meeting and suddenly
forget or say you know what I just have
to think about a little bit longer I
really do feel like I just tricked
everybody to make this game as big as it
was but you know that that to me was an
amazing moment that was when a bunch of
really talented artists go into a room
and just let their imaginations run wild
and I think you guys mmm you turned my
name yeah you guys you guys are the ones
that assigned Charlie as the name for a
tray is someone mentioned that to me
this morning they're coming in and I was
like that's not real that ever happened
we found that video of you doing the
interview I think here was an extra
Kratos voice actor and you were saying
like I don't know where Games would like
out that I don't know where we got it
either and I can only imagine does the
Sun have a name by the way
GameSpot says it's Charlie Charlie
Charlie I don't know where that came
from and I know
come on old weary watch the video like
listening super close this morning we
couldn't find it anything okay so then I
mentioned this cuz this is entirely
possible I made some dumb joke that been
misinterpreted or something like that
but then they were like he has a son and
his name is Charlie and honestly it was
the funniest thing we thought it was rad
and so I was like this is going in a
game at some point and the writers just
came up with an idea and they said we're
not going to tell you we're gonna put it
in and I'm I found it in a playthrough
and I nearly fell off the couch while I
was like this is the greatest
implementation of that ever that article
is still up with the name Charlie and
forth I refuse to change I don't fancy
that's part of history man how's it
going charlie is your witch friend here
what is that name that's what he told me
it was what it sounded like in my head
anyway Charlie did you open the
beginning or was it something that came
out of the process that Reyes would be
Loki
I really wish we could say that from the
beginning that was the plan but it was
not Matt Sophos and and rich go bad the
two writers and I'm working with on this
brilliant writers that wrote Lost Planet
3 absolutely underrated underrated story
in my game is so freakin good but they
had come to my office one day and said
they had an idea and they wanted to
pitch it I was like all right cool
and their pitch was verbatim the lines
that were used in the game that's how
solid it was you know I was like yeah
you know be recounting the story of
looking at the mural and say he
understands all this stuff he said but
was weird is he didn't understand they
kept getting his name wrong in the mural
they kept calling him low-key and he
even said it the way that sunny ends up
saying it low-key and I was just like
you guys I wish I came up with that idea
it's so good
I'm totally gonna take credit for that
nose is utterly like just that aha
moment of I I knew in the beginning the
part of this story is about identity
right and the identity lens that I was
looking at it was how much of ourselves
do we show our children right how much
of our true selves to be shown how much
do we try to portray the superhero that
is without a fault right and it's very
hard to show the negatives it's very
hard to show that we are not perfect and
we make mistakes and we've done dumb
things in our past because we feel it
might undermine our sort of authority I
guess with our children but there is an
amazing part of this the part that sort
of blossomed right in that moment which
was we don't often get a chance to
choose our identity right we get that
moment when you go to a new school when
you go to college where you get to
reinvent yourself when nobody knows you
and you get to be who you wished you
were right but this idea of going
through the entire game and being
referred to as a trace and and actually
sort of bonding with his father and
having these breakthrough moments and
the sort of coming-of-age tale and then
realizing that his name could have
loci and that it is a name that she
passed on and wanted him to learn but
only at that moment only at the moment
at the end when he'd gone through all of
this stuff so that he can then not
probably not in that moment but in the
future start wondering if that is a part
of himself he wants to take on and if
that is maybe truly who he is
right it is that you know do you take
the last name or or do you keep your
sort of maiden name and then how does
the child feel about the connection to
that maiden name versus the the sort of
taken last name concept and this was
even more extreme because of how
electrically charged the the name loki
is and how he is connected to so much
more and while he may not have done any
of those things he might start learning
about some of those things so it's it's
a really cool thing that that that was
born of the organic process of just
working with awesome right that's why I
absolutely love love making games with
teams because other people's projectors
makes things so much better
no it resulted in a fantastic game yeah
absolutely well thank you thank you very
much I mean we're so proud of this thing
and seriously that was a beautiful
review by the way so I think it was it
was very amazing
I appreciate that but your game was the
one that born it's born it that's born
it you hear our game born it
[Music]